من بعض الاحياء القريبه من حاجه واحده من
الطريق يعني كعب النمره الاولى يعني
المشاكل
الثانيه بعد ذلك يعني
الواحد يصل
وما يلقى يعني على اساس
خمسه اشخاص فقط يشكلون الكادر الطبيه الذي
يقوم برعايه الاطفال المرضى على مدار 24
ساعه يعني
المشكله دي برضو
العيانين قد يكونوا محتاجين مستشفى
الحرب الداخليه منع الطفلا مريضا من
الوصول لهذا الجهاز فكان الموت بانتظاره
كما حرمه القتال من رؤيته هذا الرسم لطفل
اخر مر على سرير من تلك الاسره وقبل
مغادرته خص حائطا بالمشفى بهذا الرسم
وارفقه بجمله قصيره تسم للحياه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات